hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde wir schauen uns heute mal wieder
einige models an
das kann nichts werden du bist komisch
danke nein nicht so komisch er so wie
mein nachbar der um ein und nachts
klingelt weil sein aquarium brennt
ich habe gesagt das kann nichts werden
heute meine kleine nichte hatte heute
morgen bauchschmerzen ich doppelpunkt
dass sie daran dass dein magen leer ist
sie hasst deshalb auch so oft
kopfschmerzen 1 0 für deine nicht
einfach mal von seiner nichte so gedisst
werden aber wohin mein bruder gefragt
warum er lehramt studieren will und
warum er damit ich später einen an kreuz
test machen kann wo immer zäh die
richtige antwort ist und zu gucken kann
wie langsam panik ausbricht
die armen schüler aber das stimmt
wirklich
wenn du in dem ankreuzt die ganze zeit
den gleichen buchstaben richtig hat es
sagst du irgendwie
abitur
schatz du sagst mir gar nicht mehr dass
du mich liebst ich habe es dir einmal
gesagt wenn sich was ändert sage ich
bescheid so präsentation von mädchen
haben ganze thema studiert 200
karteikarten dabei fünfmal präsentation
gelernt reden 20 minuten und zwei wochen
vorher vorbereitet jungs thema einfach
wikipedia beitrag fünf minuten vorher
angeguckt freestyle reden maximal zwei
minuten ein tag vorher angefangen so
oft habe ich sogar am gleichen tag dann
in der mittagspause angefangen ich habe
meine oma von meinem lernstress erzählt
und das meinte deine oma acht du musst
nur mehr essen das sagen omas immer
egal was ist man muss einfach mehr
kuchen essen und so du hast das gefühl
du hast zugenommen ist einfach mehr
kuchen versteht seine mathe aufgaben
nicht einfach mehr kuchen essen du bist
kein kuchen mehr essen einfach mehr
kuchen essen bei den sohn hat sich heute
morgen tot gelacht weil ich zu arbeiten
muss während der ferien hat kenne ich zu
gut ich habe dann einfach das wlan
passwort geändert um mein gott das hat
mein vater auch mal gemacht ich war
gerade bei lidl einkaufen und ein typ
vor mir ist ein brötchen hauser sind auf
den boden gefallen und die kassiererin
hat gesagt möchten sie ein neues und der
typ meinte passt schon heuer boden ist
wahrscheinlich sauberer als die täler in
unserer wg das
könnte eins zu eins so von sandra kommen
to kleiner und du glaubst nicht was der
dhl fahrer gemacht hat ich gucke aus dem
fenster ich sehe den dhl boten einparken
der dhl mitarbeiter sitzt im auto und
tippt in sein gerät dhl fährt weiter und
ich bekomme eine benachrichtigung auf
mein handy die sendung konnte ich
zugestellt werden ja
welcome to my life das ist hier jeden
tag so und wenn es richtig gut läuft
wenn er das paket nicht wieder mitnimmt
sondern meinem nachbarn abgibt steht auf
der sendung benachrichtungen einfach nur
drauf nachbar
hier wurden gefühlt 70.000 leute welcher
nachbar ein freund hat mir gerade seine
neue smart watch gezeigt was hat er für
eine ich wollte wieder einkaufen eine
apple smart watch aber welches modell
weiß ich nicht genau ich habe erst mal
schnitzel stadt schritt viel gelesen
mehr muss man über meine sportliche
aktivität nicht wissen
heute im supermarkt konnte der kassierer
meinen artikel nicht einscannen
keine ahnung ich doppelpunkt ist
bestimmt umsonst der kassierer hd mix
habe ich noch nie gehört dafür bekommen
sie das jetzt umsonst ich doppelpunkt
wirklich kassierer doppelpunkt nein
nicht repariert bei meinen eltern gerade
eine steckdose ja und so was machst du
doch jeden tag mama doppelpunkt aber
vorsicht da als strom drauf ich 24
gelernter elektriker weiß scheinbar
nicht dass auf steckdosen strom drauf
ist das ist genauso wie wenn ihr mit
eurer mutter autofahrt
ich stehe seiner ampel links rechts
apple wird grün
ich fahre so rüber
[Musik]
ja mama
ich habe im spiegel ich sehe den
richtig umgehen habe ich den typen
fahrrad anruf während der mittagspause
ich welcher idiot ruf während der
mittagspause an er wissen sie wer ich
bin ich bin der vorstandsvorsitzende
wissen sie wer ich bin nein
noch mal glück gab das ist dann gut geht
bild
heute war es bei uns zu hause ziemlich
warm weil mein freund ein feuer gemacht
warum macht dein freund ein feuer an
eurer wohnung warum ist das lustig
stoppel kommt ganz schön warm hier dann
sieht doch deinen pulli aus ich hab
nichts drunter
kurze stelle
doch einen pulli aus der typ dating und
flirten und all das durch gespielt ich
nicht mal angefangen habe zu spielen
eine 50 cent hüte bitte zwei sitzungen
einen center shop zwei schlümpfe und wie
viele habe ich noch 15 cent
ok dann noch drei mauer im kracher das
ist einfach eins zu eins die wahrheit in
meiner kindheit also professor es gibt
keine dummen fragen student ist
selbstmord nicht eigentlich notwehr weil
man die person tötet die versucht einen
umzubringen okay wow
ja
es ist halt
ich nicht falsch wohin muss ich mich im
bus so zusammenreißen wieso der bus war
fast leer und ein mann hat sich auf den
behinderten platz gesetzt eine frau
meinte dann total wütend der ist nur für
behinderte mann steht auf und sagt
entschuldigung ihr setzen sie sich bitte
gerade ist meiner schwester das auto
abgewürgt mies meine kleine schwester 15
neben mir du bist so hässlich bei dir
kommt nicht einmal mehr die kupplung
sehr ordentliche disco heute zwei mädels
und ein mann sind in einem vierer
gesessen bruder
was ist ein vier mädchen einst alle
männer sind gleich alles erst der mann
daraufhin die hat doch keiner gesagt
dass du alle ausprobieren muss der ganze
abteil hat gelacht bruder es heißt das
ganze abteil sprachen lernen dabei habe
gerade den heftigsten des meines lebens
bekommen erzählt ich doppelpunkt der
rock ist doch etwas kurz oder die
freundin meinte daraufhin ja der wollte
partnerlook mit seinem schwanz
[Musik]
u
der hat gesessen ich bin doch jetzt arzt
in der notaufnahme ja hat mir mal
erzählt kommt ein mann mit einer kleinen
platzwunde am kopf in die notaufnahme
ich klebe ihnen die wunde mit einem
spezialkleber zu der patient darauf hin
wie nennt man das verfahren die frau des
patienten bei dir ist das dann eine
hohlraumversiegelung es richtiger
ahlmann humor wie man eine beziehung mit
dem wort du beendet sie doppelpunkt wir
hatten zwei wochen keinen pr
doppelpunkte du ja das ist das ist frech
schauspieler küssen sich für ganze acht
staffeln ohne dabei gefühle füreinander
zu entwickeln jemand hält mir die tür
auf und ich denke ganze sechs monate
darüber nach das stimmt damals in der
schule alter wenn irgendein mädchen mit
mir gruppenarbeit machen wollte ich
dachte direkt ist nämlich verknallt die
für mich heiraten
ich arbeite doch in der schule zurzeit
in der hausaufgabenbetreuung ja und ein
erster meinte wie alt bist du ich
daraufhin ich bin 25 der erstklässler
denkt angestrengt nach der doppelpunkt
schade dann kann ich dich nicht heiraten
bis ich erwachsen bin bist du schon
längst tot war vorhin sind im bus zwei
grundschüler eskaliert erzählt weiter
die haben sich halt gestritten und auf
einmal sagt einer deine mutter ist so
dumm die denkt usb ist das nachbarland
von usa
dk
erstklässler kommen auf solche disse
und ich
ich komme auf gar nichts
auch sex schuld an der stelle durch die
heutige episode watts entfällt jetzt
allerdings ob meine lieben freunde wenn
es euch gefallen hat das gerne einen
daumen hoch und dem video da abonniert
main kanal feldzug einen teil der luxus
sein und wir sehen uns morgen in dem
neuen video wieder wenn es wieder heißt
haben sie gedacht als der ball im tor
war
[Musik]